what's happening there reject nation
we're gonna watch ourselves superman and
lois season two episode 14 worlds war
bizarre
alrighty well thank you for being here
leave a like that'd be extra appreciated
also suicidal subscribe and click that
notification bell to get notified when
our reaction for i think the final at
five no i don't know like 18 more
episodes like 14 14 more episodes 20
more episodes yeah we'll milk it we're
gonna divide the final episode into six
parts
and
release them four weeks apart like the
way how they like to release this show
and also full length watch along as we
sync up with the time code are available
for the super recessive for sexy rejects
over at our patreon page thank you all
who have joined us so far been fixing a
lot of the kinks over there a lot of
pervs over there in the kings and we're
fixing a lot of that and it's a special
tier to do a special video explaining
what i mean by that soon and yeah
prepper boys thanks for helping said
that sound and girl girl yes not just
boys ladies boys and there's one there's
a specific lady at our team anyway
well we treat you like an equal you're a
guy to us
that's the ultimate achievement all
right let's get to it
his palms are hairier than i thought
his palms are hairy
robin williams superman kind of
commentary
here at the real reasons
he wore suit superman
hey [ __ ]
does he stop for a sec
he's just like you jonathan oh
weak you must train him to be human now
according to the dod ali completely
drained your cells of all solar energy
it's gonna take some time no
no something's wrong
the sun's not recharging me i need to
get solar panels in your house
i think there's some government rebates
you can apply for we need to figure out
how her power works so we can defend
against it
come in come on
now's your chance guys he's human kill
him kill him for what he did to your
planet
[Laughter]
what a twist
i'm tired mom this is what tired looks
like running around town like a crazy
person taking care of you two while
trying to learn this job now go throw on
some clothes gosh you're so cranky in
the morning
you look good tired a great tired i'd
date you tired
listen before we meet up could you pull
an all-nighter
there's just
one thing left for us to do
merge both earth
who is that
i don't know
[ __ ] it sarah look clark superman
jordan's got powers
that's why everything's absorbed it
doesn't matter anymore
it's our job to warn people it's not our
job to create panic it's a perfect time
to panic i'm lost andy is gone
soup story
your cells
have been severely damaged
altered by whatever power ali also has
inherited from the pendant what does
that mean
altered change the dna there has to be a
way to speed this up
perhaps there's one but it requires
mother
mother
he missed some very important piece of
information
oh
eerie god ally you're such a [ __ ]
i'll get back to you as soon as i can
i need to fly into that
that's the sun for me
satellite data is inconclusive have you
heard from lucy she's with a team of
analysts fully cooperating
characters off screen
probably being the most palatable she
could be at this point but she's
somehow using his energy to do exactly
what she said she would do merge the
worlds
we have no clue how to stop her
uh you'll figure it out chrissy just set
a meeting with lana she wants to go
public with everything she knows damn it
i knew we shouldn't have brought her
with us when we track lucy down actually
i think she's right
lois she'll start a panic that's a
perfect time to panic
we're lost andy is gone
yes we can
and until we find a solution we damn
well better
shut chrissy down
killer
take the shot jesus christ lane do you
have any idea how many times you're
wrong in this show
just look at your pattern of judgment
people always object
representatives in the department of
defense have been clear that this double
sun also known as a parheleon is caused
by sunlight refracting off atmospheric
ice particles of course it is
i need you to be with the girls so i can
make some calls okay mayor lane
you know anything about this
no
why did we elect you yeah why haven't
you figured this out
i'm gonna
set a town hall at the high school
it would be great if you and your team
could be there just help keep everyone
calm
yeah yeah chicago whatever you need can
you bring your axes
fire hoses yeah and some maybe some
barking dogs or something make sure to
wear your masks
could you bring riot gear too just in
case
uh census indicate that red sun is
putting a less than three percent of the
total solar radiance of our normal sun
so what we're looking at is some kind of
mirage
no it's real
and the energy output's growing fast god
you brought your daughter out there yeah
man
might as well
we need to identify an energy source and
track the point of origin we're working
on that now sam i'll give this info the
dod let me know if you find anything
else gotcha how's retirement
[Laughter]
seem like
busiest somebody can just do your job at
their place now
that's what retirement is
just being able to call your own shots
while doing the same thing
you stopped her from killing me
if you did anything wrong
it was saving me
nah that's not true no we need you dude
is he okay
he will be in time then why are you
telling me all this
so i can play along with that cover
story lie to everybody to help keep them
calm
no
the exact opposite i am telling you all
this so that you are armed with the
truth it's up to you to decide what to
do with it
oh
chris is like she's only talking about
journalism
[Laughter]
you just rose up a notch in my book
let's get back to the office
dad
dad can't even hear you
get inside
oh my god jordan stay away from my dad
jeez ah crap stop
take me
oh you coward duke it out father
daughter duke it out that was cool
okay
not too late to catch that nut job
i'm afraid we have bigger problems than
her yeah that's some menacing ass music
from the data we gathered there is a
distinctive energy flow that seems to be
coming from the schuster mines now let's
just drop a few megatons of american
muscle in there
well the energy trail
in the space between worlds she's using
the power she stole from me to pull the
two dimensions together i'm gonna go in
there i'm gonna take her out
no we're gonna go in there and stop her
together
what can i do to help
stay here keep everyone calm can't have
you going out there risking your life
clark godspeed you two
pathetic clerk
weak
weak hearted
weak heart clark
don't know what to do you know most
people they they can handle that but it
is difficult being the one
telling the truth when the truth isn't
good is that why you didn't tell me
about tanya because it's easier oh
now's the time you have this secret and
you keep it there long enough it starts
to feel like it never happened
like this lie that you've
created for yourself is
somehow actually
the truth
i love denial i'm i'm sorry i
i don't even know if that helped no it
did
look can you um get the girls
i want to talk to them first before the
town hall we're gonna die
[Laughter]
so go pack up everything
maybe like get underground i don't know
jordan it is not your job to protect
your dad from people with power yeah
well it's a good thing because i can't
none of us can
you know other jonathan would have been
able to
yeah i mean
the giant would have smacked her down
right there i don't want to give people
false hope
that's not what i'm saying
the world needs you
you're superman
be
superman
do you know what she's getting at
show up to the town hall and talk to
people dressed as superman
that's the best i got
as i understand it there is another
world like ours and soon
soon
you are gonna see people
from that other world doppelgangers the
hell are you talking about
this guy i wanted you all to hear it
from me first sounds like you two are in
cahoots we're trying to save lives
george seems to me that job's best left
to superman miss mayor
oh
superman has lost his powers
and he will not be coming to save us
today
you can file a formal complaint
everyone just let me finish where did
you get your information from
hey can we all just give her a chance to
spend evil dies tonight
doesn't have any real answers just the
frightened talk of someone who's in way
over her head you better stop right
there george why so i can listen to more
garbage about
worlds melding and scary look outside
the goddamn window man your whole
world's red
maybe i can help with that
oh
she's telling the truth
i'm gonna go to the car now i need to
lay down
but i heard all that and it's it's it's
on the money your mayor is telling you
the truth i saw what this town was
capable of last year and i know you can
do it again
that starts
by listening to your leader because i
know she is here for you
not to serve her own interest
how's it feel george she's not here for
you george the people from this other
world may look just like us but they
have a very different agenda
stay by the people you love and we will
get through this
together
girl's gonna leave you're not gonna ask
for superman's autograph
it's a world's ending i might as well
isn't gonna stop until superman is dead
so you have to be there to protect them
while i'm gone sir your suit is at
maximum power help me by staying on
comms and gotten me back
i think it's a fair trade yeah
damn they got something really special
on their hands but
john henry irons is the main character
in the show yeah
it's
such a good call
i wonder if that was always the plan um
i'm gonna go track sarah down
and then
let's meet at home okay oh
yeah i'll see you there
rub one out
i'm ready for the night
and rock and roll nice
kyle's back
man i'm happy for kyle it's been good
and it's been a good arc
i feel
oh
like
what
prepare for impact
impact
oh
dad do you read me
roger
i made him
come on
we gotta get home
okay um
oh god
oh my god jordan's gonna show his powers
[Laughter]
my dad were alive you two could have
merged
but i guess since he's dead
you might as well be too
god damn it reading's clean target's
locked
trump's over this oh no
you caught her
oh yikes
come on at least put up a fight
leave him alone it's already over you've
lost
the all is lost moment
come on jordan
this is the training you've always
needed
[Laughter]
yes
oh damn yeah jeez man
[Music]
ally oops oh no
oh she went to the kent house
mom i broke up with him i wouldn't if i
you should have just told me that sarah
tamira we gotta be the face oh no what
are you talking about
oh
golly
ah crap
it's their house from the other earth
oh
plan yeah
stupid stupid ugly plan you don't want
to merge
you don't want to you don't want to fuse
with your
shadow self
your
strained yourself
so what is the impression that they're
under
like
dumb lana and dumb jonathan
what is the impression that they're when
they emerge
that they're gonna be like powerful like
ally is that the illusion they're under
i guess so yeah everyone's gonna unlock
their maximum potential and whatever
is missing will be
filled and what does
why is ally the only one who can be come
like super saiyan
i don't know i don't know if it's just
because she's the only one so far we've
seen who's like really done it
because yeah when you merge your dot
right like we've seen that happen yeah
emerging fails and i thought
i could have sworn that jonathan and
evil lana were
made privy to this at some point yeah
um but maybe i'm wrong i'm not sure or
maybe they release these episodes every
four to six weeks
it's like wait a minute hold on let me
jog my memory maybe it's some kind of
cultish thing where it's like if you're
truly worthy the fusing the uh you know
merging will be successful and if you're
not then you know too bad for you
cosmically yeah
i just get i guess i don't know exactly
like why
well
you guys are [ __ ] morons yeah this
seems way riskier than it is worth the
trouble this this would be a little
compelling if i i guess i guess i need i
could use some clarity here i'm not
saying the show hasn't done that i could
use some clarity here
of
um
why is why is there people who are on
board for the merging and what does
no not that i know why people are on
board because they think they'll become
this like ultimate self of them
why does what what why does ali want to
do it
if people just die from it
what's left what
left for her yeah yeah what remains
after a merge basically
just a desolate planet she's like thanos
on a farm
what is it supposed to be for her yeah
unless it's yeah unless it's some
kind of just utopia but still yeah there
i feel like if there's one
there's so much i love about this season
and these this episodes in particular
but if there's one thing i do wish had a
little more
meat on the bone it would be
actual
character time with ally so that all
that stuff is a bit more clear and that
at least
like i get the nuts and bolts of it but
she is among the more sort of like
she's really great at generating
physical stakes yeah and motivating a
lot of action and a lot of great
conversation but as
her motivation and as her plan by
extension then goes yeah that is a
little
more vague in my mind compared to a lot
of other things which on the one hand
i'll take because i love what they
choose to focus on but also
you know yeah it would be nice to to
have a full read on
what her full end game is knowing yeah
the risk
yeah
more so i'm like yo i'd like a better
understanding of the of the app super
saiyan diabolical alley merged alley
because i liked ali before uh she became
merge alley i like just the
the cult leader
version of her
and not this [ __ ] nazi
um
yeah i just wanted a little bit more
meat around it but as it stands
uh from everything else i'm able to uh
grasp onto which is most of it
the microphones picking up those bird
noises
that's just me hearing it through
here i can't tell
i can't either this will be a good
experiment we'll see
if you guys hear bird noises and if you
like the bird noise we'll increase the
volume on that
good separate audio track for those bird
noises
outdoor reactions indoors um
yeah i i really i really think that uh
like an episode like this
knows how to hook us i think you know we
have fun when we're watching this show
um each and every time it's like we make
jokes that's not something that
that does not mess with our immersive
uh the immersion that we have with this
with the show i don't know
i want people to know that because i
think some people might misconstrue
uh because you know when when a time on
this show
comes time to like pack a punch
or hit you in the fields it gets me you
know like like natalie
showing up at the home and
um all
sad about dad wandering in the quantum
realm yes um
that was that was that was a really like
when i really would really hit me up
like where she turned to
um you know not just the people that
she's protecting but who she needs his
family at this moment i'm like oh what a
great demonstration of character art
and that's really sweet that was really
touching and i really like how they've
shaped natalie on this journey so far
but come on mvp jordan this has been his
[ __ ] season jordan dude
yes one from first season of oh my god
is he gonna become an [ __ ] carol's
already won
to
uh the hero
i i love i love moments like that where
if they have no choice but to reveal
their power yeah and and you know the
second i felt it like oh my god he's
about the darkness yeah yeah it's like
you're so caught up in the moment and
yeah it has to take a second to register
you're like oh dang it's i love when
when they can
what it feels like effortlessly
orchestrate a moment like that where
yeah it's it's the sort of volatility of
information spreading but then
oh no there's
a superseding event that renders all
this conversation useless now like and i
think that's that's a great way to drive
the drama forward like they're really
great i think at balancing things like
that in this show and also legitimizing
the time like when sarah was like
recounting like wait a minute you were
acting this way and then this and jordan
was doing this it all makes sense and
i'm like wow it really does feel like uh
the way she remembers it is how i
remember it and i think that's a really
a testament how gracefully they're able
to draw these and and yeah to like have
these
super salient emotional beats but then
have just these like super cathartic
action moments that yeah are
cool and badass and have good production
value for the most part but also mean
something to the characters oh a
thousand percent
joe's action scenes were amazing i mean
natalie showing up was so rewarding yes
and uh i i really think they they do
such a great job at layering everything
without it being a
cw scene without it being a rehash of of
what we used to complain about it's like
it's not safe you can't and it's it's i
love that sort of baton pass of like
look i know you want to come with me
but you have responsibilities here yeah
yeah you know and you have other people
who look out for you and also
in a in a means of protecting you
emotionally you have this family unit
you can turn to if the worst like i love
the way
john henry played that scene because
i was like i don't
logical brain says he's not gonna die in
this episode it's gonna look very
perilous for him but like emotion brain
was like i feel like his choice here is
is saying goodbye because it could be
the last time yeah he's being very
reassuring yeah i was very specific on
the way it was directed because he
wasn't like disciplinary or scolding no
you know um it wasn't like it's
dangerous for you nat no
in fact he was right if nat didn't stay
behind they would have been dead they
would have lost yeah so having
morgan edge that's going to be the sea
key
is going to happen he's going to come
back they've been bringing him up this
episode yeah he's going to be the key to
being a hero in all this yeah i love
that so much so call him morgan edge
he's always morgan
yeah
taro's cool and all right morgan edge
for like a billion episodes before
one of the best romances in the show
kyle and morgan edge so yeah morgan yeah
that's right
uh yeah
and i think the way they
they just explore nuances so well in the
conversations like that scene with
nat and john henry irons or even the
the the
the conundrum that
lana's in
with do i tell the people the truth or
do i lie so they don't have to worry and
they could just enjoy their lives
you know and then how that
starts relating
how that allows kyle to
show how much he's learned through it
all and how he's mature when they you
know they
because they they talk
what i think they have they handled the
affair situation so well is the way the
affair gets brought up and you watch the
communication on that develop
in a way that becomes less tension
between them and more understanding and
you watch how they've evolved
over the course of this time of being
separated that they've really earned
their way back into
them being a a unit again
um
what if in that scene kyle left the
garage to go be with tanya
he's back on [ __ ] tapping
her i thought we were broken up we were
on a
i'm glad you took motivation from it
yeah yeah so that or even um
like i think the way they they they
infused
superman uh being
not just showing like hey
he can be something you know there's
there's a phrase that i heard
um i'm not religious but i i heard this
when talking when someone was once
talking about jesus
uh it's that uh
for all that he is the less for all that
you are the less you have to say that's
when i first heard that
and that's kind of what a demonstration
was there yeah it's like
we all trust superman superman's the one
from another world superman deals with
the craziest [ __ ] all the time so
superman says it's real okay let's all
listen
yeah superman come in here use your
platform lend your credibility to this
moment so that yeah maybe people won't
lose their minds and i love it's kind of
weird how you have such a bias for small
little i know
who is that in smallville is this uh is
this uh truth spread gonna happen in any
other city
are you gonna show up still smallville
can you get on tv maybe just be like hey
guys
superman here going broadcasting
worldwide
this threat is real um
yeah that's a great question but i think
for the for the most part in smallville
i like that they too like there's so
much made of that point in this show and
in various other shows where it's like
you know you have your reporter
character who's like we gotta tell
everyone the truth and for various
reasons we are collared from being able
to do that and i like that they
did the thought experiment here of like
you know what let's not you know count
out to the cover story and let's
try and give people the truth and i love
that it's everyone's having this like
mocking and adverse response at first
they're like this is insane you're
freaking crazy like it seemed really
practical the way that they imagined
that out because it's i feel like that's
a philosophical debate that often comes
down too easily in the decision-making
of like well no just people need the
truth or no people need to be able to
live and i the way they expanded that
conversation both in the group setting
and then in a more intimate setting with
her and kyle yeah like i thought was
really
choice and also like an instance of a
very relevant conversation that's not
like the you know the the
few that are very obvious to be having
right now
well
what i what was really clicking with me
in this episode especially for being
penultimates really it's really
important that it does
is
it's all
it's all coming together
and what i mean by that is not just like
plot [ __ ] but
the emotional stories are all starting
to come together like the brilliance of
the writing is really starting to shine
through now to me because you've had
so many different things happening here
with this bizarro world and then lana
finding out the truth and you're dealing
with all these different subplots and
then you watch in this episode how it's
all coming together and how
the situation as as the the bizarro
world and the merging
escalates like that's the the physical
plot of it
now you're seeing the emotional beats
these these emotional character journeys
are all being tethered together through
the development of that plot now where
you know you have lana uh i'm sure she
that's a bit a bit of an aid in her
emotion in terms of opening back up with
clark and and lois
over the fact that clark did show up to
the town hall meeting when he's
feeling under the weather and then you
have uh when lois decides to look i
really learned my lesson we should tell
the people the truth like this situation
is causing the character resolve of
these people
sarah learning the truth about jordan
that secret coming out finally to her
and i think that's really cool because
before it was like it was kind of like
there was zig-zagging all over the place
and we got like so many different story
lines and then here now i'm like oh
that's cool how they're using the the
the culmination of the merging
to truly
um
let it uh what am i trying to say feed
into the emotional beats of all the
journeys as opposed to
just kind of cutting back and forth like
oh no it's actually at all it is all
tethered together and i think that's
really cool of how
i didn't really see that coming and how
how that would all
actually go about it's not just like
clark saves the day and then london's
like you know what but it changed my
mind
yeah you're watching like all these
different plots
even even with nat being put in this
position and now being one with the
kents like i think that is so great i
think that's really great writing
because i didn't see that coming at all
no but the best part of the writing has
always been lucy lucy
why wasn't she here because that's just
the final cherry on top that we need
just to wrap that up yeah she's got
another pin in there man she's with the
dod they're figuring it out she's fine
be good she'll be back for the finale
yeah and and even how they've used clark
being like they've had clark be absent
they've had uh they've had clark be
absent when he was gone for a month now
clark has no powers which has really
forced us as audience members to
adjust to the fact that we need other
heroes in this show that's not like pull
characters from the hero version you
know like john henry irons nat jordan it
allows them to really elevate and and
those moments feel so rewarding
and uh so i think that what they've done
here like with their penultimate to see
it all kind of come together with all
these
with with the emotional journeys and and
what these characters have to learn and
resolve with each other
it i love that it's being solved
it's it's all coming through and through
like through specificity of what's going
on with the merging you know yeah i mean
what i'm getting at dude do you get what
i'm trying to say yeah i mean i feel
like they're really good like i i admire
the writers of this show very much
because i think they're good at using
the amount of episode like you know you
watch a show this long and i feel like a
lot of shows will fall into
a trap of having certain episodes that
feel more pertinent than others and i
feel like in this show they really use
all of their time to the
to the richest extent and they're good
at over
depicting the interplay between
macro situations and micro situations in
individual and communities lives and so
yeah it's like all these things feel so
alive because they do feel like in some
way they're all kind of pinging off each
other and affecting everybody in a way
that's
some ways very upfront and in some ways
very subconscious and yeah it's just i
think a testament to
the amount of humanity they're able to
to depict and and two what i was
admiring in this episode is this season
in retrospect has been able to do two
things i think really
cleverly that are tropes now which is
you know the sort of sequel or part two
movie two season two being sort of the
exploration of what happens when the
hero doesn't have their powers or
something like that and also
now that we live in the you know the
time of the multiverse i think this
doing you know bizarro world is is well
worn and well known but you know it's a
parallel you know alternate dimension it
is technically part of a multiple
universe but it's also not doing that in
a way that makes you go i want to see a
million other universes so it's like
it's super relevant but it's almost
like under the radar in how it's doing
those things too yeah so yeah it's like
it's it's really
i think yeah they're just really really
good at looking at their whole story and
again those timings of things with the
arcs like really figuring out because
because i really marveled at the way
they had
at first i was like oh they're gonna
have the tanya conversation now
but then i was like but this is so
relevant to this situation and this is
such a kind of real life moment and this
is a developing you know arc situation
that you know this conversation could
have happened in a different tone
episodes ago and yet this feels so alive
that it happened this way yeah and so
there yeah there's like a poetry in the
way they write where things feel
not like yeah you have plot mechanics
being like oh you know we got to show
people in peril or we got to have
superman decommissioned for a while but
what's the fastest way to get him out of
that it's like no how does how does
anything that happens affect everybody
and how do we make that interesting yeah
you know
yeah i think they i think they're doing
an excellent job and i'm excited for the
uh final episode i think um
i think my favorite part about watching
these is
when i read hate comments about
how we watch this and then
they couldn't feel like if you stuck
around
for the reason you'll be like oh you
guys really actually didn't take this
seriously i think i'm like yeah maximum
yeah praise and dissection yeah i have
fun with it but i'm also i'm very very
very much paying attention over this
going oh yeah i'm wrapped like i i when
we're
because of the weird airing schedule
it's easy to kind of get distance and be
like oh you know but when we're back in
and i'm like i don't want these episodes
to end yeah they're very it's really
enjoyable yeah it's really enjoyable so
yeah anyway guys thanks for being here
uh what'd you think about this episode
what's your
favorite for the final
episode
leave your thoughts down below and hey
let's do a patreon
i literally said before this shout out
who do you want to merge with
sounds like a change
hundred percent
one word
oh
you're funky and artistic and i think
this will be a good uh shout out for
this video you know and if there's like
two versions of you
merging with each other
like i wonder what alternate bizarro
gene would be like you know he'd
probably be like super st
he'd be a white guy
he'd be
i work at the grocery store
and i don't like to get too adventurous
anything i do
like my life lived inside the lines i
love the idea of another gene who's just
like
i'm white jesus all lives matter
is the exact opposite yeah yeah yeah i
like my fox news in one kind of movie i
don't like the idea of all these women
posing on social media that's
anti-christian the way they show them
bodies we already gave them the right to
vote now they're out here cavorting in
the streets that's possessed to satan
i make short films that are a real
simple a b and c plot now right i always
follow save the cat of robert mckee's
story structure that's all i know
if it's ambiguous it sucks i love the
idea of those two genes merging together
yeah because because what would it be
i guess they would just merge into kind
of an intermediate gene who's like a
little quirky
we've had some conversations with gene
on instagram a while ago when things
weren't so uh
wild
and uh yeah send him some funny ass [ __ ]
dude
you got some like
some taste and really good comedy oh
yeah dude yeah and gene gene always
funny i i look forward to the voice
messages he sends too yeah yeah i want
to do a community post for you
i haven't forgotten no no i got it it's
good we got we you know go we've
scheduled the juice schedules
i was just like i'm going to put it off
the day where obi wan miss marvel came
out i'm going to put it on the next day
and have its own time to show you yeah
gene thank you for being here buddy
you're the perfect kind of weird
kind of weird we love
weird like you you are the weirdos
mister thanks dude need a bomb
[Music]